comparative aspects of diet and
amazonian forest dwellers
in which she looks at the dietary
ecology of four forest living indigenous
groups the arara parakana arawete and
maruru mayaruna
i did not find here what i went looking
for which is her initial observation of
combo being used but um
this paper is actually super fascinating
so zach if i may have this back for a
moment
um so she um i'm just i'm gonna share
a few of the conclusions and then show
one more screenshot and then have us
talk about this a little bit
um she she this is actually this is
really good work she starts with a
hypothesis which i'm not gonna share
until
the end this is not simple descriptive
this is not data driven
this is hypothesis-driven science which
is particularly tough when you're doing
cultural anthropology so
she looks at four tribes all of whom
inhabit uh what's called terra firm
amazonian forest there's a lot of
flooded forests there you know a variety
of forests in the amazon actually but
these are all
these she she goes she goes looking for
and at four distinct tribes
that are not exactly saint patrick that
is they don't overlap but then
tribes don't overlap in the amazon and
that's part of what's going on here
but they inhabit very similar ecological
spaces right
that is to say um even people who know
the amazon could walk into the forests
in which each of these four tribes live
and
immediately see a lot of similarities in
terms of the species composition
so they all of them have distinct both
carb the plants
that they eat and prey diet compositions
and i wanted to
say just a few words specifically about
the prey um so the arara
are dietary generalists specifically
here i quote the arara consumed the
widest range of prey species including
stingrays and electric fish
the intestinal tract of a wide variety
of mammals and pintos
milton reports in her 92 paper pinto
from 1989
reports that vultures house rats and
hawks are eaten by the aurora when other
meat is not available
but the single most important prey item
of the aura was monkeys particularly
capuchins
okay so they they they get capuchins the
most
um they i don't remember if they state a
preference for capuchins some of the
other
um tribes do state of preference even
when it's not predominant in their diet
but they're really wide generalists so i
would just point out capuchins
are almost the only thing on that list
that sounds like it would be at all
palatable to somebody who
shares our diet because they're
frugivores um
i don't want to eat house rats but yeah
in a pinch
yeah um yes uh completeness of
frugivores and freakables taste better
than carnivores or omnivores yep
um and full of ours taste taste good too
uh
full of wars including grazers
yeah grazing almost all of our meat
animals are full of horses a
rain forest full of ore might be
particularly awful by virtue of all of
the toxins in
in the leaves of durable oh actually
so we're getting to something
interesting here uh so the parakana
and incidentally none of these four
tribes that she was looking at are any
that we have um spent any time with we
haven't we don't
i didn't at least didn't know any of
them by name the parakana are
specialists on terrestrial game in
particular land tortoises
tapir peccaries which is wild pigs
armadillo
and paca which is a big rodent they
report that they are most
interested in eating tapirs however
whereas both the arara and the arawate
say that they avoid eating tapers
whenever possible so they didn't get a
lot of tapirs when she was
there observing them and instantly she
took in all of her own food which is
pretty rare for cultural entopolishes
but she took in all of her own food
in order not she brought in she brought
in
all of her own food to prevent the local
people
from um either hiding food that they
found particularly precious they didn't
want to share with her so that she would
get a skewed vision of what she was
eating
um and to avoid um basically changing
how much they needed such that they had
to hunt more and thus change the
fractional composition of what they were
eating so really well done again all
right who were these people
uh those were the parakana who
specialized in terrestrial game and
these are in
um in um this is in the brazilian amazon
okay
so and they avoid eating tape here no
oh yes sorry yes yep no no no no they
prefer eating tapir and
the arara and the arawete avoiding
avoid eating tape i must say there is no
job
on earth easier than avoiding eating
tapir
given how skittish and hard to find this
animal is it's really
it's amazingly easy not to eat tape here
if you're hunting all of your own food
and so for those who don't know tape
ears are
big they're really big and one tapir
could feed
a village for a while yeah but if it's
not your thing i mean you're not going
to find yourself
accidentally consuming a tape here it
just that's probably true
oops i killed a tape here got to eat it
yeah yep
nope um okay the arawete
uh again uh brazilian amazonian people
specialize on large birds including
macaws and toucans
right um plus
two can i can almost see but not only do
they specialize in your macaws
but they have macaws as pets their
villages are filled with pet macaws
and their diet is leaning heavily
towards macaws that they are catching
wild and eating
catching well but not raising not
raising interest
what do those pat mccaws think macaws
are freaking smart they have theory of
my them
and and and uh i want to see covid's
corvids
like the crows and jays are incredibly
smart social
long-lived generational overlap all of
this they must be appalled so
they are feeding yes yes they are
feeding these macaws
the pets presumably i don't know maybe
not i
i understood you to suggest that they
were um
catching and raising for food these may
cause
or is it no distinction they're hunting
macaws and eating them and then they
also have peppercorns they also have pet
macaws that they never eat
so apparently you know this is this is
almost a throwaway line in this paper um
that i found
i was unable to track down further but
you know the author here milton who
again
seems to have been doing really careful
work back in 1992's when it was
published
um lived in the villages with each of
these tribes for some period of time
and you know was was a careful observer
and cultural anthropologist
and usually a primatologist
um oh also the arawete unlike all three
of the other tribes that she's
looking at have no dogs and they have no
desire for dogs when asked they say why
would we have dogs whereas
all the other three tribes are largely
have dogs and use dogs to help them hunt
and when you say dogs are you talking
about domestic dogs are you talking
about forest dogs that they have
domesticated i believe
she doesn't specify but i believe we're
talking about domestic dogs given what
we've
seen in um yeah so this would be a
modern
change sure yeah yep exactly um
oh one more thing the arawete apparently
also have 45 different classifications
for
not snow as as you might imagine but i
would imagine they have
none right they don't have a word for
snow i'm making that up but probably not
they have 45 different classifications i
don't know if classifications means
words or what
for honey that makes perfect sense right
oh man in an environment like that where
you have so many different source plants
um yeah and age and a lot of different
species of bees although most of the
bees aren't going to be making honey
yep yep yeah but there are more i mean
there's it's not just apis malifa i
think that makes
that is going to be making uh honey is
it it's apis it's other apis
uh i don't know i am
venturing again on that i would have
said maybe it is but yeah um
but i don't know okay um or you know
really the question is make enough honey
to be worth pursuing
right um yeah a solitary bee is not
going to be yeah
worth pursuing um so finally we have the
maya roona
who are actually in the peruvian amazon
um who specialize in peccaries
but they state that they prefer eating
tapirs and sloths
even though tapers and slots are harder
for them to find and most their diet
consists of peccaries
and this is a little there's a little
violent so you know close your ears if
you don't want to hear how they
how they deal with the sloths when they
find them quote sloths are captured by
climbing their tree
lassoing them with a noose made of vines
pulling them free and then clubbing them
to death on the ground
that's the that's the sloth killing
activity yeah um
and while she was there probably a lot
more humane than
you know what other option do you have
yeah i mean you could you know you could
do you shoot them out of the tree and
have them fall that ain't going to be a
fun death
yeah which is uh you know how how at
least
some uh like let's at least have the
lorani um things
yeah um and oh incidentally spring of
the morani milton the wahrani who
are people whom we have spent time
around and with
in the ecuadorian amazon um she points
out that the diet of the mayaruna or the
people i was just talking about actually
most closely matches that of the
warranty
um so that is that is
that is more similar to something that
we have known um
the mayaruna have the longest list of
foods that they will not eat
of any of the tribes she looked at and
here we go
some that are developmental stage
specific so for specifically with regard
to howler monkeys yeah
adult marijuana do not eat howler
monkeys but children do
wow that's exactly the opposite of what
i would predict right why
uh because howler monkeys are obligate
folivores
and the toxins are liable to be more
dangerous to a developing
child or a pregnant woman in fact there
is a lot of anecdotal stuff and i
believe a certain amount
of uh data to suggest that
um uh aversions during pregnancy
may be about protecting fetuses and
things so um
anyway i would have expected an obligate
full of or a to taste really terrible
in a landscape like the amazon where
there's so many species
and the obligate full of oils themselves
are sampling from a wide variety
yes where they're taking in the
secondary compounds of the plants
that have produced those secondary
compounds in order to protect themselves
right right
exactly so anyway um yeah what is the
explanation for
uh yeah i don't know lots lots of little
juicy stuff in here right and some not
so juicy stuff
including macaws yeah which uh charles
handley he didn't specifically
tell me about mccos but he told me he
was uh
a uh the great batman of the uh
smithsonian
and one of your mentors a mentor of mine
on bci um and uh anyway i've
forgotten why he found himself eating
parrot at some point
but he uh he reported that it was
a lot like eating a shoe
[Laughter]
so i'm guessing macaws are rather like
that yeah no i have um
i may actually have less interest if i
had to choose if i was starving i had to
choose between monkey and parrot i
really don't want to have to ever eat
either but yeah um
oh monkey yeah stands
not just for edibility actually oh i get
there i don't want to eat a monkey
because it's a monkey but
from the point of view of what would the
meat taste like except for
howlers which are the exception all
those frugivores probably taste just
fine
yeah yeah um and peccaries surely taste
good yeah i mean if you like bacon you
probably like peccaries
it's a pig i bet it's a lot leaner but
um
and also you know tapirs might
you're you're convinced not no no oh you
know you think they're tapers
yeah because because they're giant
ground dwellers so they're in part i
mean
the intact amazon doesn't have much to
graze per se but the browsing at ground
level
um is um i think
i mean maybe just because there's a lot
of new growth that they're going to be
able to access
and the new growth has fewer secondary
compounds yeah and i'm about to eat a
lot of
fruit too yeah
and the thing that is most famously
delicious
are um the uh paca
the pakas and a goodies they're supposed
to be absolutely delicious yeah
those are those are big big rodents yep
and um and you know
are mentioned once here goodies are
never mentioned in capybara never
mentioned
um but i imagine um that the large
slow somewhat dim ground-dwelling
rodents get hunted out
pretty quickly yep yeah yeah that would
be
likely yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna
catch it from all of the capybara
enthusiasts out there for calling them
dim but sorry compared to
most other things on this list they are
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you